Now that we've introduced these factors
and to find them, we're now able to
describe the fundamental law as
expressed by Richard Grinold.
And it's simple, it's just this.
He was able to show mathematically
that information ratio
is equal to information coefficient
times the square root of breadth.
I'm just going to present it without
proof here and encourage you to go look
at Grinold's book if you're interested,
for more detail.
So, performance of the manager, or
the fund, is due to the skill
at making predictions.
Times the square root of breadth.
So that means, for instance, that yes,
you may be very skilled but you've got
to have opportunities to invest in
order to operationalize your skill.
Now if you want to improve your
performance you can either
focus on improving your skill or
focus on improving your breadth.
Sometimes it turns out,
that it's a lot easier to increase
breadth by finding additional stocks you
might look at or additional markets.
You might have some commodity
trading strategy that works great.
You can increase your breadth by
looking at additional commodities.
However, the strength of this increase,
in other words, as you increase breadth,
the overall performance only increases
as the square root of that breadth.
So it tapers off after
some amount of time.
It turns out, though, that it's very,
very hard to improve your skill, so
that is why,
for instance, folks often focus on
the breadth component of this equation.